lorsque l'on passe rappelle parité
déchets concernés
ma mère est ma à béthune dit il
maritchu
le point culminant de la côte d'ivoire
dont le nom n'est pas révélé exactement
1753 mais parmi cette forme c'est qu'en
2008 750 arrêté traitement 1750 gare
viger tombe sur le nom qu il subit
chaque année plus tard et mots et les
gigolos six finales il est le maître
en tout cas probables qui est entré dans
l'hôtel
je veux dire et qui m'a répondu par
écrit ce qui paraît qu'il est
[Musique]
e
escalader le mont et var je vais
demander à leur place je t'appelle
et ensuite lui et lui sonore bien sûr
c'est un peu partout séparer fait
mention d'une demande 'est-ce que tu
pars en arrière
c'est une bombe à l'estivé oswego qui
lui lit bien sûr et puis ça fait classe
je suis avec vous
parmi eux mêmes
don mattrick conf réussi en dioula etc
m
mission beau celle fiq magnifique
abidjan nous connaissions tous qu'il
fallait savoir sur le monde là bas
merci papa google nous avions toutes les
données nous étions un prêt à traverser
une bonne partie de la côte d'ivoire
pour enfin arriver au fameux village de
ya le ya le dernier village derniers
bastions de toute présence humaine avant
l' aventure avec le monde là bas nous
étions frais comme vous pouvez le
constater nous avions nos beaux
vêtements achetés dans un magasin
d'appeler ma bouche chapeau rose tout
neuf des citadins au village nous
allions tout déchirer jour j du ce 4
nous voilà nous sommes de retour nous
arrivons à ian e nous sommes sales ça
fait quatre jours que ne sont pas lavés
nous ne sommes plus beau nous avons
perdu tous nos très clair nous ne
serions plus et surtout nous sommes
silencieux mais notre différence notre
regard a changé notre porte de tête est
différent notre démarche est différente
nous avons le regard des personnes qui
ont arpenté le chemin qu'a menée au plus
tard effectivement ne sont plus tôt mais
nous sommes devenus extraordinaire
exactement comme dans dexter est donc
que s'est il passé
nous retenons trois sons
le premier
[Musique]
ce que je dis quel que soit rêve
célébrons chaque étape avant d'atteindre
le sommet
ce qui était difficile je pense que je
vais me rappeler là de la première parce
qu'on a quitté le visuel de ville aldeia
le est entré dans la forêt en fait ces
jeunes au départ la paix la forêt et
après on s'est rendu compte que les
jeunes on a marché pendant près d'une
heure et une heure et deux heures et on
l'a reçu comme étant comme une gifle
je lui ai dit bon remonter une pente de
près de 40 degrés tout était mou on
avait mal partout on suffoquait on
arrive et on mangeait tout le monde se
demander mais qu'est ce qu'on fout là et
ça c'est seulement au bout de deux
heures alors qu'on doit fait plus de
deux jours de marche
on s'est dit on va individuellement
basse on a un peu honte l'un de l'autre
enfin peu marre et d'enseignants
individuellement je pense que on va pas
y arriver mais c'était pas le pire
le soir lorsqu'on a eu enfin droit au
repos on a subi une attaque de fourmis
magnans parce qu'on a eu la somptueuse
idée de manger juste à côté de notre
tente donc on pouvait pas dormir parce
que dans là j'ai des fourmis magnans
sont les reines n'était pas le pire
on s'est retrouvé dans une forêt de
sangsues et médias nos amis qui étaient
pleins de sang sud
c'était pas le pire le soir tu dors tu
te réveilles tu as le visage marqué à mi
purulent parce qu'il ya une bestiole on
sait pas laquelle on la cherche encore
si vous la connaissez quitte à piquer
les villas du visage dont le pourtour
des oreilles et ce n'est pas le pire est
à chaque fois
et le pire c'est que si jamais c'était
quelqu'un nous avait amenés là on aurait
dit
il faut que ce gars partent en prison
non c'est nous mêmes on est venu on dit
on va on va connaître de mon mba mais
une chose extraordinaire parmi toutes
ces difficultés
c'est que fois à chaque étape parce
qu'il y avait une pause et lorsqu'on
regarde
lorsqu'on tombe bien sûr quelque chose
d'extraordinaire parce que des choses
extraordinaires
il y en a toute cette douleur pas si je
lui dis les pistes ils sont bons flics
les sangsues le pus tout ça tout
disparaît et le souvenir le plus
mémorable s'annonçant s'est retrouvé à
près de 800 mètres d'altitude dans une
savane
on traverse la jungle dont surtout d'une
savane à perte de vue on se demande mais
qu'elle se passe est le seul dieu comme
de la roche et en fait on se rend compte
que c'est une savoir qui était une forêt
avant mais qui a subi deux une activité
volcanique et tout a été rasé et c'est
magnifique
tu as l'impression de te retrouver dans
jurassic pas puisqu'ils connaissent
c'est juste extraordinaire et on tape
comme des enfants fatigué il ya une
sorte de reggae d'énergie ont été lancés
demandé ensuite on savait qu'on était
les seuls à voir ce paysage là et ont
célébré et on devait y aller en été
prise parce qu'il y avait encore la
bleue mais à chaque pause
si on reste est magnifique et c'est
qu'on peut retenir de cette étape de
cette leçon c'est que les limites
finalement ne sont qu'un écran de fumée
avant la prochaine étape de notre rêve
la deuxième leçon que nous avons apprise
pendant cette aventure est la suivante
quand on choisit un objectif plus grand
que soi
malgré des doutes on voit toujours du
saumon
nous voilà dos en pleine jungle à la
haye la poursuite de notre rêve
atteindre l'objectif le sommait richard
mode un peu plus au sommet de la chaîne
de montagnes du monde là bas nous avons
tous été attaqué par une chose est prêt
commune et que nous avons tout ce qu'ils
appellent le tout
le doute le doute cette petite voix qui
nous dit tu ne va pas y arriver je n'ai
pas assez forte physiquement non je n'ai
pas assez prêté pas les uns c'est la gym
c'est pas possible pas passer de souffre
je n'ai pas assez grande tu n'es pas
assez petit tu pourras pas combien plus
vite que tout le monde cette petite voix
petite voix que nous avons tous et
qu'ils nous attaquent
quand on commence toute entreprise dans
la vie et je me taire pendant 5 secondes
pour que nous et q pourquoi nous
écoutions tous cette petite voix
cette petite voix vous a dit pendant ces
cinq secondes mais quelques petites fois
je n'entends rien lp trust celui-là
cette petite voix et elle nous a tous
attaqué individuellement pendant cette
aventure et le souvenir que j'ai de ce
moment de tout était de deuxième jour je
me souviens sous la tente comme une
bonne citadine
j'ai planté maintenance sur un gros
caillou et j'ai posé mon sac de couchage
sur un gros caillou donc incapable de
dormir
en entendant des bruits d'être de la
bouche je suis dit mais est-ce que je
vais vraiment y arriver juste tellement
fatiguée je n'arrive pas à dormir
est-ce que je vais vraiment pouvoir me
ressourcer en juillet cette aventure
le deuxième grand doute nous a tous
habités et là c'est un groupe a un doute
collectif qu'attaquer toute l'équipe
c'est quand nous sommes arrivés à la
deuxième pause après la savane donkey ça
parle alors nous sommes arrivés à un
deuxième plan que nous avons tous
baptisés le camp riesling et sans et la
particularité la particularité de cette
pause est que nous n'avions plus de vie
parce que nous avions programmé deux
jours dans cette aventure est en fait un
cheval de troie et nous rester une
journée à parcourir nartuby
nous n'avons plus d'eau pour faire
commerce que nous continuons maintenant
aventure nous sommes et fusils
et là nous regardons tous nous demandant
je pense que l'aventuré va s'arrêter là
à cette pause
ndao rentrer sur abidjan mais pendant ce
moment il y avait une chose pense quand
envoyé deux sommets et charvaux là
pendant tous nos moments de doute
pendant toute notre erp version sur ce
sujet et voir ce que nous avons appris
si nous pouvons créneau tout
nous pouvons également et détruire et
atteindre notre objectif et nous avons
détruit collectivement ce truc
voilà ce que nous avons décidé et
installations numéro 3 quelle que soit
la situation de chaque personne
nous pouvons tout déchirer en équipe et
comme mes frères sud africain tirait au
bout comment est-ce que nous avons
surmonté cette épreuve
ce tout connecté nous avions deux choix
soit laisser les personnes qui étaient
physiquement plus forte continuer
l'aventuré atteindre le sommet seul et
laisser les personnes qui étaient trop
fatigués derrière ou la deuxième option
que nous avons choisie est la meilleure
il a été de dire que les personnes qui
avaient encore des ressources physiques
allait descendre à 800 mètres chercher
de l'eau pour tout le monde est remonté
les 800 mètres afin qu'on puisse tous se
ravitailler et avoir l'énergie de
continuer de grimper ce sommet ensemble
et je suis convaincu que cette décision
cette décision de continuer cette
aventure en équipe qui a complètement
transformé cette aventure
nous sommes arrivés sur le mont nimba
comme crise myriam youssouf moussa
astrid mini ariane et nous étions tous
alliés rachid également de tunisie ils
sont venus et à partir de cette décision
nous sommes pas enfermés en équipe
notre jeu est venu nous et ça c'était la
beauté notre aventure qu'est devenue une
épopée humaine qui est rapide au delà de
l'ascension du mont d'amin
des choses qu'on peut résumer notre
expérience par cet homme par ce proverbe
en anglais qui dit tout simplement
il fume on topic ils ont toutes offert
en tout cas ne se voulait aller vite
marcher seul si vous allez devoir
marcher ensemble
photo comment quand on monte pas mes
rêves on a tous un très bon soir on a
envie de créer la multinationale on a
envie de crier de sauver des millions
d'enfants en a envie de faire plein
d'autres choses
non seulement les flics en cabinet
d'avocats en afrique l avocate donc mais
cela à deux exigences
la première c'est qu'il faut continuer
malgré le doute il faut continuer malgré
la larme le sens il faut continuer
malgré la douleur la deuxième c'est
qu'il faut s'inscrit dans une dynamique
d'équipé il faut il faut interagir avec
des gens avec ta communauté agir pour
eux et envers tous individuellement ici
on a tous nos poumons nîmes bat on a
tous notre challenge personnel
on a tous cette ivresse du sommet cette
voix intime qui nous dit vas-y il faut
juste l'écouté et aujourd'hui
si j'ai mes autos devant la maîtresse al
bateen double
et qu'elle me demande de savoir crise
est-ce que le monde n'aime pas je n'ai
pas uniquement lui parler de ses 1753 m
j'ai lu pas allé du sourire des
habitants de ya le jld a lui parlé de ce
magnifique les levers de soleil qu'on a
vu je lui parlais de l'extraordinaire
dévouement de ces deux agents cahier
lébamba de l'oipr je lui parlais de
notre guide
sylvain qui nous a pas dit que le mont
nimba appartenaient à trois familles
ancestrale yacouba qui appartiennent aux
trois pays
tu as dit la côte d'ivoire le liberia et
la guinée
je lui parlais du crapaud vit pas le
seul au monde celle sur le capot d'une
au monde minuscule et le soir lorsqu'on
était en pro duo doute en crapaud on ne
voyait qu'on ne voyait absolument pas il
nous est apparu comme dans un sens comme
pour demander continuer et enfin je veux
lui parler de la sensation que c'est de
marché juste entre deux pays et de se
faire traverser par des nuages
et en fait je vais lui dire madame
double
[Applaudissements]
je vais lui dire madame thibout le monde
mba ne fait pas 1753 m mais 1759 m il ya
un film qui s'appelle claude à plat ce
qui est assez méconnue mais qui est un
chef-d'oeuvre
et dans ce film ya une phrase magnifique
et il dit toutes frontières toute limite
est une prévention qui aspire à être
profonde et une convention peut être en
santé pour peu qu on conçoit que c'est
possible
quelle est la frontière que la limite
qu'est la convention que vous allez
transcender aujourd'hui nous vous
remercions
[Musique]
et
moi
[Musique]
et